okay so um thank you uh everybody
attending this this this talk uh uh I
want to thank um uh Veterinary
bioscience Institute and lab Roots uh
for giving me the opportunity to discuss
uh what I'm going to present uh uh to
you I think it's an interesting H topic
uh and and the talk is going to be
around uh uh Gren husbandry and and the
environment we keep we keep the animals
and the uh and the impact that this may
have and this is a very important thing
may have on experimental uh uh
results
um uh so let me uh let me start with
this uh uh with this chart uh uh
representing the uh uh the logic or the
mechanics if you will of a typical
experiment so we start uh with a
biological question biological problem
uh and then then we formulate an
hypothesis uh and then design
experiments to test that hypothesis
hypothesis um then we apply we run the
experiments with our treatments our
controls and then we collect we we we
get the data the results uh and then by
uh or through the analysis of those
results then we find a conclusion to
answer that uh
biological problem or question um so
ideally the difference uh in the results
that we that we see should come from the
uh from the
treatment
um uh but this is always this is not
always the case right uh and and this is
basically because there are a lot of uh
factors that can
influence uh the data that we collect
from from an from an experiment
um these uh these factors can be uh uh
due to to to the experiment uh itself it
can be experimental factors like the uh
uh the the the experimental design uh
the the treatments that we apply on the
animals how we uh uh apply those uh
treatments uh how well train the people
running those uh experiments are
handling animals um data collections
errors from data collection or or even
the equipment can be a can be a factor
uh influencing so if equipment is not
calibrated uh things like that uh can
can influence those those results
um but more important for our discussion
today are uh the uh um the the the
non-experimental factors right and I I
have divided those non-experimental
factors for our discussion today uh in
uh intrinsic or animal related factors
the uh the physical environment and the
nonphysical
environment uh uh let let me also say
that the uh the uh the control that we
that we choose uh for the experiment is
extremely important that's not the
discussion today
uh but the the control is going to have
an impact in that difference because we
are comparing the treatment with the uh
with the
control
um so uh we've seen very very you know
very high level overview of of of of
these factors and how uh diverse they
are and but uh let me remark here that
all all factors that uh that can impact
uh laborat animals may have and again
this is I would like to remark that may
have an influence on on
results um obviously if these uh factors
affecting the animals are are not fixed
then uh this is when they become barbles
and then this is where the problems uh
may
start so uh let me uh uh um um exp a
little bit on on non-experimental
factors
um I I have divided these
non-experimental factors into intrinsic
or animal related factors uh like the uh
the age of the animal uh the the gender
of the animals the genetic background we
we all know how important the genetic
background is the microbial uh Flora of
the animals uh it's uh and this is an an
expanding f Feld at the moment the
healthy status of the animals that is
obviously an obvious influence of on on
their results um the the physical
environment also have and this is what
we're going to discuss uh uh tonight has
an impact and I'm going to give you
examples of of of this uh impact uh but
the variables the main variables of this
physical environment uh can be you know
temperature uh humidity uh noise is uh
light also very important for for
rodents um the sarian ridens and and
this is um in in in some cases uh this
this is classified or I have seen this
as an animal related factor and in fact
it is an animal related uh Factor but
the environment has uh such a
powerful uh influence on on circadian
rhythms that uh for the discussion today
I'm going to consider that as as part of
the physical environment of the of the
animal um and obviously the non-physical
environment so these parts of the
environment that are non physical
uh actually
influence can or may influence the the
result and I mean uh things like the
interaction with with other animals uh
even same species or different species
the uh the husbandry procedures the
handling of the animals this is very uh
um uh very important and I'm going to
show you in a minute a few ex examples
to illustrate uh this um also the staff
you know we have husbandry staff animal
caretakers uh scientists technicians
performing experiments all that is going
to is is going to influence uh uh the
results it's going to have an impact on
the data that we we collect from uh from
the
animals
um so so these non-experimental factors
we can group in uh the ones that are
animal related and the rest is the
environment and that's that's going to
be the uh the discussion uh uh
today um we know and we all know that
the environment uh have an impact on on
reproductive uh parameters on animal
welfare on experimental results which is
the subject of the
discussion um today um the reproductive
uh parameters in rodents are are very
well characterized so uh it is it is
easier to see a deviation or to identify
a deviation in these in these parameters
and and then may we we may be able to
link a problem in the environment with a
reproductive uh
problem um also Animal Welfare we can
also uh you know assess and and and and
also not easily but at least be able to
to link deviations in this Animal
Welfare uh with uh with the conditions
of the of the environment um but it is
it is much more difficult to link uh
deviations or U influence on the
experimental result s of this
environment simply because of the very
nature of the uh of of research uh in
many cases we don't need to uh we don't
have uh um anything to compare with so
um it is it is a lot harder to identify
the influence of the environment of the
in the uh experimental
results um and and and this impact or
this influence of the environment is is
is is
you know is critical for the uh for the
discussion of the results as I just said
a minute ago um and so that's that's why
uh it's so important the standardization
of the animal model
uh the environmental parameters and the
experimental protocol and all these will
uh make our experimental results
reproducible uh which is you know
uh the the the the the central uh uh um
subject of science uh the fact that we
can reproduce those those results so the
impact of the environmental conditions
on the response of of of an animal model
uh we could we could describe uh using
this formula if I if I if I can put it
that way uh so the the the genotype of
the animal plus the environment Plus
what I am studying what CL test will
give us the uh the
phenotype um I said the genotype plus
the environment plus the test and this
is not entirely true because it's not
one plus the other plus the other is is
uh is a lot more one influencing the
other influencing the other so it it
becomes a lot more complicated but
anyway let's focus on the uh on the uh
uh environment so anade quate
environment for the for the animals must
provide socialization for for the animal
this is critical for social species like
rodents and many other animal species um
must provide to the animals the ability
to exercise uh uh also the uh to promote
their physical development the
behavioral development um it is also
Paramount Animal Welfare and an optimal
health status so these
are you know features of of the of an
adequate
environment um let me remark also here
that we we start from uh uh from uh from
minimum standards that are uh described
in the uh in in the laws that that
regulate animal use so an adequate
environment is also described in in the
current regulations that we apply uh it
can be the guide in the uh in the US and
here in Europe much more the the new
directive uh um so uh this this is this
this set of regulations give us a uh you
know a minimum standard for the uh for
the environment of the of the
animals
um let me you know describe a couple of
things before I I get into the uh
examples of how the the environment can
influence uh the results uh just to make
this distinction and the uh I'm sure you
all know that the primary enclosure or
what we uh describe as a micro
environment and the secondary enclosure
or the uh of the M mcro environment the
uh the primary enclosure is the uh is
the cage where we keep the animals while
the secondary enclosure will be you know
the broader environment the the the room
usually the room where we keep the the
animals um it is uh very important to
note here that is a combination of both
what really defines the uh the the
quality of the environmental
conditions so let's uh start discussing
uh uh or getting into a little bit more
depth uh talking about the the micro
environment uh uh there are many
parameters that can affect uh our
research uh results
um some of them and I I I put this here
and in no specific order but available
space uh per animal is is a is a very
important parameter the number of
animals per cage that's also critical uh
I will give you example of individual uh
versus uh group housing and how this
influence uh
you know research results that you
wouldn't
imagine if you didn't do the test uh the
cage size uh the environmental
enrichment another uh very important
factor uh and the quality of the uh the
materials and the equipment this can
also have an impact on the on the
experimental
results so just to illustrate and I'm
going to give you examples here that so
the purpose of the talk is not to
discuss the results that I'm going to
present here this is just these are just
examples uh but let me let me uh I think
that they they're very illustrative of
how uh these environmental parameters
will influence uh the research um so
this is a study uh where they compare
individually H grouped individually
housed mice with group house mice in
pairs right so uh I don't know if you
can uh see very well here but this is
they they measure and this were measured
by Telemetry uh the heart rate and the
body
temperature and this uh and they measure
that in during periods of low middle and
high activity right so where you see the
uh the differences here with the uh with
the Stars
those are significantly statistically
significant uh differences so just the
fact that the animals were uh singly
housed or in pairs uh is is got an
influence on the uh on the heart rate
and the body
temperature it is also this is also part
of the the same study and it's it's
interesting that the uh that the
activity of the of the animals is is is
also different uh is also different um
these are the you know the the 24hour
day then they follow the uh the activity
uh and and and you can see here that in
in animals that are housed individually
or housed in pairs um you can see that
the the activity is different you see
high activity here what the while the
animals housing groups are in middle
activity mode then when they become
highly active then the singly housed
animals are not so active um in this
24hour period the lights
will go on like around here so you can
see that the pattern is also uh
different there's a period of low
activity uh here for the uh for the
group house or the or the Animals House
in pairs compared to you know
Interruption of these low activity VI
periods of midle activity in the singly
housed animals so this is just an
example of how uh um something so simple
as house in the animals singly or in
pairs will impact parameters like
activity uh heart rate or or body
temperature um this is another example
um and it's I think it's very
illustrative of how
uh housing mice in groups or or or or or
individually will influence h a
different study this is a a force
streaming test um and and they test uh
compound to see if they have
anti-depressant uh uh activity so you
can see here in in in white uh the
animals hous in group and with this
shading uh light gray uh animals that
are singly housed right
so if you uh compare the uh the control
with uh two doses two different doses of
that compound and look at the duration
of the immobility which is the what we
measure in the force swimming test you
can see that uh the result results for
uh the group housed animals indicate
that there is an activity there is a
there is an effect of this compound on
the duration of immobility while if you
compare with a singly house um there
there's no effect for that compound
right um You can also imagine that if we
had uh a mix of singly housed and
grouped house animals this will make the
uh the whole thing more um difficult to
to to
interpret uh let me give you this
another example of of a a different
parameter in in the uh in the micro
environment or in the environment of of
the animals we need to handle animals
you know for the cleaning for the
experiments uh uh that's unavoidable but
uh uh uh let me illustrate the uh the
effect that handling animals may have on
experimental results or physiological
parameters this is a a a study where
they compared
um mice uh that were changed the the
cage was changed once a week or every
other week by weekly so every seven days
every uh uh 14 days um there are
variations that you know they're not
statistically significant uh that is
also important for uh for experimental
results and and I will discuss that that
later simply because they are
introducing noise in the in the analysis
of the data um but if if you look at
this uh specific uh uh parameter which
is uh plasma cells uh you can you can
you can see here that uh just by
changing the cages once a week or every
other week uh we see a difference which
is uh pretty much double the uh um the
the parameter so it's got a a clear
influence on on on on physiological
parameters this is another another
example just to illustrate a little bit
more how handling uh in this case uh
pregnant uh rats or uh can influence in
and in this case what they measure was
the uh the the the the fetal body weight
so they stressed or they handled uh the
the rats uh the uh the third gestational
date the fifth or the uh or the seventh
and these are the controls um and they
found what that when they restrained the
animals the animal the rat the pregnant
rat just for a minute
uh on gestation day day 7th then when
they collect the fetuses on on the on
gestation day 18 there will be a
different uh a difference uh with with
what we see on controls right so it's a
it's it's just a a um is not a is not a
big uh alteration so we're just
restraining the animal but the effect we
can
see this is part of the same uh
experiment and you can see some other
parameters here and I don't know if you
can see it very well I will try to
highlight uh some of them but uh they
they uh they handle the animals they
they restrain the animals
on um gestational days 1: 4 5 to 8 9 to
12 or 13 to 16 and you can see uh again
it's it's not the purpose of this talk
to disc discuss what's going on here but
you can see
difference right see differences here
statistically significant differences
here
there more there right so just handling
the animals will have an impact on the
physiology of the animals and and
therefore on the
results um but the uh the micro
environment is is is a lot more complex
and and we're you we're usually looking
at a combination of of of different uh
parameters um this is another study just
to illustrate how the combination of
these different these parameters uh can
influence in this case just uh
reproductive parameters like the uh pre-
wind mortality in mice in this case and
and and production of animals mice wind
for them so what they compare here are
uh pears and
trios uh and these animals were kept in
in in ivcs in IND individually
ventilated cages at uh 30 air changes
per hour 60 air changes per hour
renovation of the air indicates 60 times
per hour or
100 uh and they uh what they did uh is
to change the cages uh
once a week every other week
or once every three weeks so again we're
not going to get into the uh into into
details but you can see that there are
uh there are differences
uh looking at the uh the different
combinations right
so uh in this case the uh the um the
renovation of air the environment in the
cage and the handling has different
impacts in the um in the breathing
performance of these of these
animals by the way it looks like U um
one of the you know best uh conditions
for for keeping these animals could be
around 60 uh air changes uh per hour and
maybe handling the animals every other
day so that that's anecdotical I think
what what is relevant here and what I
want to uh to bring here is that uh
there is an effect there is a
combination uh uh of of of
effects um let me uh touch a little bit
on environmental enrichment there there
is a lot of discussion on on
environmental enrichment and uh so I'm
I'm not going to go into into details
about what whether environmental
enrichment is good or is bad or is good
for certain experiments but not for
Behavioral study and and and things like
that um what I I would like to bring
here is that environmental enrichment is
another Factor uh that may alter or may
influence our experimental results let
me uh
um um make it uh clear with this example
here that uh
that
animals seem to prefer an an an an
enriched environment right so this is an
experiment where they uh offer the
animals um uh slightly enriched
environment like just the cage plus the
GRE and nesting
material um or just simply the uh the
the Box just just the cage so this is
the time the dwelling time and it is uh
it is clear that the animals prefer to
be uh or to dwell they dwell more in in
in in in the enriched
environment so well that's the
preference of the of the animals but
uh the fact is that environmental
enrichment may have an impact uh on
experimental results and again it is
important here the word may may have
because if if the environmental
enrichment had an influence that is
always uh of the same magnitude in the
same direction then we could you know
live with that but uh it looks like uh
it's not always the uh the same for some
parameters it's very important for some
others it's irrelevant for some studies
it may have a a huge impact for some
others it's um not so relevant
um this is a
a just to illustrate something that we
we we all know that environmental
enrichment has an effect on on mouse
behavior uh it's pretty very obvious
that uh uh uh an an enriched environment
will have an effect on on activity and
and playing behavior and we can see this
here uh I don't know if you can if you
can read this but this this will be an
standard cage an enriched cage with
nesting material and a super enriched
cage with additional complexity in the
uh in the cage um and you can see here
that the differences are statistically
sign
If part of that study uh as well uh was
to measure some physiological parameters
and once again it's not so important
here uh what those parameters were uh
what is uh more relevant is that they
found uh differences statistically
significant differences in in those
parameters uh depend depending on the uh
uh standard cage enriched environment or
super enriched
environment um so for this study they
found uh these differences but uh let me
bring here another uh study where they
measure hematological uh parameters like
uh white cells uh red cells hemoglobin
or the hematocrit of the of the animals
and in this case we using different
strains like
a strain black six or b c um and in this
study what they could see is that the
effect of the um uh genetic background
The Strain uh was significant in many
cases uh but not the the housing not the
difference in the
uh in the in in the housing conditions
uh and and reach versus not enriched
right um so this is again to illustrate
that for some parameters you may have an
impact for some others uh it may it may
not uh and and let me just just bring
another uh set of results um here is
part of the same study uh but this is uh
comparing uh body weight and weight for
different uh uh organs kidney liver
spleen um again is the they compared
using uh different
strains and they they couldn't
find obvious differences or
statistically significant differences um
here but what is uh uh relevant here and
the point I I would like to make is that
for many of these H results they so that
the um the animals in the enriched
environment uh had a greater variability
like for instance if you compare here
that's the the the coefficient of of
variation uh if you it is consistently I
would say uh higher in the uh in the
enriched in the animals in the enriched
environment as compared to the animals
in an standard environment like you can
see
here um so it it looks like in this case
and for this particular studying for
this particular parameter which is body
weight and organ weight what
environmental enrichment is additional
variability um let me uh continue with
the uh with micro environment and and
make a comment uh because especially for
rodents it is very very common to use uh
individually ventilated cages right um
so uh this is an additional uh uh um
factor that will influence the micro
environment of the of the animal
individually individually ventilated
cages is a is a great uh system to to to
keep the animals uh I mean it can reduce
the pathogen uh spread in case of an
outbreak uh it certainly allows a better
control of temperature and and relative
humidity um something that is also very
important the uh these ivcs reduce
uh gas contamination or ammonia
production in the uh in the cage uh and
and and also let me remark here that
they can be very efficient in reducing
the our exposure to to to
allergens so that's uh that's very good
but um I uh um just said that they
reduce the production of uh ammonia for
instance just I'm just giving you
examples and ammonia uh it's an
environmental factor that will have an
impact on the physiology of the uh of
the animals uh so I I just brought here
a couple of uh examples of acute
exposure or chronic exposure um and you
can see that exposing the animals to 50
parts per millions or 100 ppms for two
or three two hours or three days uh uh
it's got a a physiological uh uh impact
it's got physiological consequences
chronic exposure as well to 25 ppms
which is very low for six weeks it's got
a a uh phys physiological uh uh impact
and exposure to 50 bpms for for 3 weeks
uh it may cause IM immun suppression
suppression
so again ibcs in this case can be um
modifying uh the environment so if we
compare animals you know running the
same the same experiments and some and
we have animals in conventional cages
and we're comparing with animals in ivcs
they're not in exactly the same
environment even if they are in in the
same micro environment in the same
facility um so that's something to take
into into account as
well um so this was just a few examples
of uh how the uh the micro environment
can be altered uh by uh environmental
factors and and therefore the
experimental results uh I'm going to
discuss now uh very briefly the uh the
micro environment uh and I'm going to
you know briefly discuss and give you
some examples of how parameters of the
micro environment can influence
experimental results I'm going to talk
about ventilation light and noise uh
because they are the most obvious but
let me let me first um um show you a few
uh a few examples of uh
differences uh found in in in
experiments that can can only be H uh
attributed to just a different lab um so
in this in this case um and again the I
don't think the you can see the picture
very well but I will try to um to
comment uh to describe a little bit the
exper the experiment you can see here uh
uh
black um red and yellow uh bars so the
the black bars are the results of uh the
same experiments with the same animals
run in a in a lab in in Albany in New
York uh the red is in Edmonton in Canada
and and the yellow one is in is in
Portland in Oregon I think it is um so
again like the other examples I brought
I'm not going to uh go into detail uh
these were Behavioral Studies uh but
what is really really uh relevant here
is that uh uh a lot of the parameters of
the experimental parameters and animal
related parameters uh were were
standardized uh they say rigorously
equate in the uh in this study um and
and and despite this this
standardization
uh there were differences across the
labs right um and and it is it is very
interesting the the comment that they
made here that for some of these tests
the the magnitude of the genetic
differences depending uh upon depended
upon the specific testing lab so it's
not just the the experiment it's not
just the animal is the testing lab
um I think this is this is very very
relevant when we try to reproduce
experiments there is an intrinsic H
variation that depends just on the on
the
lab let me give you another example this
is a a a
communication uh I don't think is
published data but these are two rat
strains uh and these these strains were
kept uh um in an Animal Facility uh and
the the number of or the percentage of
productive matings for this for each one
of these strains were 60 and 40% it's
not very good but that's how it was um
um so there was a refurbish of the
animal facility and then the animals the
colonies were taken um to a different
room and you can see that just by moving
the animals to a different room in the
uh in the same facility uh the the
productive M the percentage of
productive M matings uh just changed
again it's just exactly they continue
doing exactly the same but in a
different uh
location and and just to to to finish
with these comments about just uh the
the the the place where where experiment
takes takes place uh just just to
comment that uh uh or I want to bring
here the uh the the variability like in
in reproduction just with with Seasons
right so
simply because of the uh the the place
the Earth is spinning around the sun we
may find a uh differences in in in
reproduction in in in
mice so let me let me um um just uh make
a few comments about ventilation is
probably one of the most important uh uh
things in an Animal Facility it it
provides the the air the the fresh air
the the oxygen it is the the main means
of or reduction or elimination of
contaminants uh ammonia allergens uh
microorganisms um it is critical for
temperature control uh and also helps
with with other control uh there
are
uh standard uh um agreement for uh for
areas uh or for the the the the what the
parameter the ventilation parameters in
terms of um temperature U
humidity uh uh should be and if you can
uh uh if you see here the uh this this
chart on your on your left um this is a
chart of uh again I don't it is very
small but I think that you can see here
this is the concentration of ammonia and
these are air changes uh per hour so the
fact that we uh uh tend to fix uh air
changes per hour 20 uh is is is simply
because uh we guarantee uh a nice
environment a non-offensive environment
in terms of uh ammonia uh at that uh
level of a changes per hour um so the
non-offensive level will be around here
so this curve is for a
um a room that is optimally up designed
so the ventilation is it's it's well
designed is very efficient this one here
is for a non so efficient uh uh
ventilation uh but you can see so with a
with a very efficient ventilation at at
about probably you know 10 or changes
per hour we we should be on this comfort
zone while for a poorly designed
ventilation we will need to
go to you know 18 20 but in order to
guarantee that the environment is right
uh we we we pick those 20 a changes per
hour um pretty much the same thing
applies the comfort that comfort zone
for uh relative humidity if you see the
chart on your right the graph on your
right this is 10% humidity this is 90% %
humidity um these are different
parameters as bacterial uh growth uh the
spread of uh Fung fungi mites and and
things like that um and we've got this
comfort zone about around
50% so anyway that being said let's
let's talk about little bit about the um
the temperature but let me point out
first that we we keep the animals are
around maybe
22° celi uh because of those regulations
and because it's comfortable for for
humans um but the Comfort the uh uh the
the the temperature that is Thermon
neutral for for mice it's it's it's
around 30° right
so it's that's important to to to keep
in mind um again a a chart or uh this is
actually an an older study but I think
it's very illustrative uh and and this
is an experiment to where they measure
um the uh the U the constant the
declining serotonin again it's it's the
the what they measure in the experiment
is not so relevant for our discussion
what is really relevant is that they
measure that parameter that experimental
uh result at 9 degrees 24 de or 34
degrees this is the Environmental
temperature um and they found
differences in
two of the experimental parameters right
so just the fact that the animals were
kept in an environment of 9° 24° or 32
degrees this this had an influence in
this uh you know uh
serotonine decline
constant uh I think that's that's pretty
uh
illustrative uh light again there are
obviously a lot more studies on on light
and how light intensity and and and
cycle uh uh has an effect on physiology
and and and
morphology um this is actually very well
characterized for alv
uh rodents and but also on the behavior
of of of Ren species
um um it is probably a very good thing
that
um we keep a dual um um
intensity in the in the room and let me
Point here
that 350 that's the the max maximum uh
light intensity 350 LS that's the the
maximum light intensity for uh for
Rollin um again before I make further
comments on on on light influence
um uh let me uh see because we tend to
think that if the environment is okay
for us uh it is okay for the animals but
uh this is the uh the uh the relative
intensity s sensitivity sensity uh of
the um the human eye and the and the
mouse and they don't see I mean this
well known that they you know beyond
this point of the spectrum they can see
so they they can't see red light and
this is this is under debate but anyway
uh and they can uh also see a little bit
on the
ultraviolet
um uh area but
um let me Des
discuss this and and and the point I
want to make here and this is my uh own
data in a in a room that we kept H just
mice uh uh so the the the uh the
intensity in the in the room was 150
looks so you may think well that's a
very nice uh lighting for a for a Roden
room uh we kept the animals in in IBC is
so you can see here uh the uh the the
the intensity of the light Inside the
Cage in these ivcs so depending on the
on the on the row and the column the
position on the rack uh you will have
intensities light intensities from maybe
22 LS to maybe two right so that's 10
times more so we're there's a lot of
variability here but um if you take the
cage from the rack we measure the uh the
light intensity inside the uh the hood
the laminar flow hood and we had two
hoods in the uh in the room in one of
the hoods the light intensity was uh 400
uh over 400 Loops well the other was the
other one was almost a thousand right
and then we also measure uh um the light
intensity when you open the cage so in
the cage when you open when you remove
the uh the
lead and in this case it was like almost
800 LS and but in this case in the
second uh Hood was over a th and and and
the third thing we measure was the uh
the light intensity at the uh the level
when you transfer the animals from one
cage to the other and you can see the
intensity of the light here so in less
than one minute minute you take an
animal um that is probably sleeping at
you know two lues then you take it h
into the hood open the lead pick the
mouse and then put it back again so
that's
a stressful I would say right so again
light is a is a very important factor uh
and light cycle is is is is very is very
important as well uh let me uh I I
brought this example here and and in
this study uh they transferred tumor
cells they implanted tumor cells in in
Buffalo uh rats and um these rats were
kept in U 12 12 uh they light dark phase
um a light contaminated dark phase or in
constant
light and depending on what environment
the animals were kept the uh the the the
weight of the uh of the tumor and then
the growth of the tumor was different
right so there is a direct impact on the
uh on the light uh cycle um in the uh in
in tumor
growth that's affecting the uh the
results
um just another comment on circadian
circadian
rhythms um it
is
that's sarian rhythms uh that's is
intrinsic to to the animal it can be
affected by by the uh By the Light cycle
but even if it's not affected if it's a
stable just the fact that they have this
Rhythm uh this give us uh variability
right so we know that animals are more
rodents are more active during the the
dark phase and and this has effect on
the physiology like for instance on
their metabolic rate um and this may
mean that the uh that the the drugs that
we give to the animals uh uh
can or the effects of those drugs can
can can vary quite a lot depending on
the time uh on of the day they they are
administered and I I want to give you uh
or to show you this example here um and
these were nude animals that were uh
implanted that were injected with cell
tumor cells um and what they measure
here were uh cells in s phas DNA
replication and
celom activity and you can see that the
uh depending on the time
they H collected the cells there were
you know maybe very significant
variations right so it is good uh it is
I think it's good advice to repeat uh uh
the experiments and the
uh about the same the same uh uh time uh
of the
day especially if they if if what we're
measuring uh um can be to cirian
readings let's discuss a little bit
about uh uh noise and again like uh with
the light I would like to remark that uh
what we
hear there is not what M can hear right
so the fact that we uh say that a a
background noise of 50 um DVA uh is is
is okay
uh this is not we're not taking into
account uh uh ultrasounds like from here
so we may be disturbing the animals with
with with
ultrasounds uh again just another
example to illustrate uh um how noise
can have an impact on the physiology of
the of the animals this is a very old
study for I don't know if you are
familiar with this silent alarm uh but
this was a a study to show that the the
silent alarm had no effect on on the
animal so um so the experiment was to to
trigger the the fire uh alarm for one
minute three times a day for four days
uh and when they did this
here uh they could see a variation on
the number of of of of
cornified uh smears cell this was in in
in rats right so right there we see an
effect compared to control animals so
that's a clear effect in the physiology
of the of the
animals um I also mentioned at the very
beginning that the the quality of the
equipment H can have an impact on the on
experimental results uh let me just
bring the case here as an example of the
the famous be phenol a uh right this is
a the normal component of of the plastic
compounds that we use uh in in many of
the cages that we use to to to house the
animals but I'm sure you you have seen
things like that the the degradation of
the the plastic material and and this is
telling us that the B phenol a is
starting to to to be
released so again to illustrate the
effect that this may have uh on
experimental results
uh this this is uh an example of the
fold increase in uh in in chromosomal
abnormalities uh measure before the uh
the cages were damaged um during uh the
uh the the period when animals were
exposed to this this phenol a and then
right here they started to um to replace
uh the damage cages and you see that
after the uh the the replacement uh the
chromosomal uh
abnormalities um came back to the to the
original uh
status
okay so I made comments and give you
gave you examples of uh how the the uh
the physical environment and the
non-physical environment remember the
handling I think can influence the uh
the um uh experimental results
um let me finish with uh with a a
comment on on also how the environment
is influences the uh the the three hours
especially their reduction and it's
simply because this variability that the
uh that the environment is introducing H
it usually uh uh causes uh
statistical uh errors or
deviations false positives false
negatives
uh because of those that that
variability we uh we may be we we may
need to uh to to to add more animals to
our experiments to to to achieve a
statistically statistical
significance um and even uh worse than
that I mean we can we can find that uh
our uh experiments cannot be repeated by
ourselves by other groups uh or even
much worse
uh and we we may find that um experiment
after experiment we um we find
inconsistent data so what we the
experiment that we run three months ago
uh we
obtain data that are not consistent with
what we are obtaining today and this
creates you know confusion frustration
I'm sure you you all uh been through
that or no s that has been through that
so okay so that that was all I wanted to
bring to for the discussion to today um
uh thank you uh for listening and if you
have
questions um I will gladly take those
questions and and and bring them to for
for
discussions so thank you very
much
okay so I have a question here uh asking
with the a copy of this presentation
will be posted for for download and I I
think so uh I don't have a problem with
that
uh I mean most of the uh the information
that I presented here is is is is not my
my own information I result from other
people I just collated everything to
illustrate how the environment can
influence experimental results so uh
this is available for uh for download
I'll make sure you can download
it
okay if you don't have any more
questions so thank you for listening and
good
night